welcome to this game playing black
against wrecked one from spain spanish
like it we're still in the opening
challenge week and i really haven't lost
have lost wrecked have lost track here
okay it's not going into a Ben Oni
steady gives me this in the central
influence and surprisingly so I'm taking
that it looks quite nice actually just
like a good guru file type of position
so it's giving me a pawn can I take this
pawn if I check the pawn and why not
actually it cannot be bad ready to take
it so um what now specialty fiber move
you might have any for them ninety-seven
may be interesting let's in such a sharp
move here threatening maybe 96 95 and
really maybe yes the takes its X now and
present the only way to do it okay that
I thought is not so I have a evident i
have a number of interesting options now
like beef I for example bee hive Queen
takes 91 going f1 can take e 2 i'm not
sure about that
95 Bishop see 6pc Queen takes Bishop d7
he can retreat hmm b5 looks very
tempting with us captured there I wait
actually I can let's do that let's do
that leads to very very cool tactical
play now Queen takes 94 I was thinking
Bishop c4 or just drop c 8 both are
interesting rook c8 he can play be three
but then I have night see tool and i
also have Bishop c4 Bishop c4 Quincy for
Luke c8 you can go to d3 and holes ok so
maybe this is 92 though I can start with
the capture on it too yeah that's it's
not a correspondence game even though I
take I take time like it it is one ok
probably be five wasn't great that BTW
to is actually ok i think
after that I always have to take it too
well okay so he's allowing 92 which
isn't necessarily bad it's just that I
thought the other thing is simpler you
will always have compensation here so
okay night 65 is some somehow in the
pollution I wonder my fatigue state
taking c4 looks really really ugly and
through q1 will be very strong then no
he threatens not take 35 maybe I really
have to play move like that looks ugly
but night xe5 is so strong if it hits
it's too much
Wow interesting main problem is my my
time spent position I don't know might
be unclear might be bad for me I don't
know at least his pieces are not super
active at the moment him
so I can play this now for at least a
tempo so jumpy for may be tending 95
check oops wow that session was too long
86 what a howler and the best thing is
after nights is t8 even my bishop is
hanging there how ridiculous can you
play ok just sheer luck that I'm not
losing yet another piece I might lose
some other stuff don't very very likely
actually going to be five probably at
least i have and i have bishop a six
year maybe Oh bishop a six
I have picture b7 actually maybe I can
just perpetually attack him we should be
seven does he have any other square them
and don't think so you can give the
queen of course somehow off I'll go back
to be five water water would be weird we
had game yeah should have been over long
ago yep so it tries to win it's probably
probably a good idea time morning k
let's go here do you fire that I did not
expect but I didn't expect almost almost
here so doesn't matter what does he have
he actually just it just it's just two
pieces to pieces and a couple of pounds
for the Queen home so I take that back
not sure if it was such a good idea my
my position is not very well coordinated
that is pretty clear but maybe I get in
queen bee six zactly okay happy to get a
tempo take your here I'm sure if I can
take let's go back I wanted to take on
d5 this is not exactly what I had
planned
to talk about a weird position I
probably should win somehow but not sure
exactly how try to h5 this is just a dry
a right way to get the rook somehow into
the game and so tanks come on I need to
get active him check oops so let's key
let's keep that keep that for him ok we
check for us the idea okay I'm taking ok
what watch a game oops check check check
check check check check always super
quick they're white for fence on time
poo ah well what a crappy game what a
crappy game
and you will publish this I guess yeah I
will yeah well I have no words there it
was it was just just not good right was
a fun game to watch yeah probably it was
ok so he's a bachelor than I am yeah so
that all looks normally when c4 I can
took here and now I had this idea that
with with be five which is maybe just
totally crazy there ok computer says
equal funny yeah I actually initially
thought I just do this this and if you
move the Queen like Roxy 192 but you can
just go here and this is probably good
like here here and I know this looks
strong yeah computer gives the win yeah
so I went here b3 and now maybe I should
really just take it to where i went here
that was my initial idea but yeah I
could have taken the pawn there yeah so
we're looking at this now it's it seems
I still a special page three I have
Queen a check sometimes and this okay
wow we are young i'm not sure i'm taking
the exchange computer is just of unequal
yeah okay this might still be okay but
now i have to go Knight b6 I just I just
absolutely here I just absolutely did
not seen Heidi six haha
JK so here in 95 and what is winning now
Queen 83 m Queen III widest two pawns up
so that that will win here and again of
course this also means but here he has
to do some mildly varying things queen
before is a good move by the computer I
have to take Bishop Jake's Bishop cheeks
and push up chicks and that's just where
this is not very nice for why now it's
got two points to bishops king is bad
and so on just too much yeah so we
repeat it a little bit here and then he
gave the Queen like that which is
probably not working but still queen d 7
is a good move now that's really a good
move here the night is a checked he has
no way to cover it and if I if you think
about this this is probably quite good
because this Bishop is not playing now
here here black is better but yeah well
that was a really just like might as
well throw some dice there okay well
thanks for watching